SHAHID HUSSAIN: Hi, everyone.
My name's Shahid.
I'm a product
manager on Chrome OS.
Thank you very much for
coming to the session today.
I've had the chance to
speak to a few of you here.
Really delighted that
you're here with us.
So today we're going
to talk a little bit
about optimizing Android
apps for Chromebooks
and large screen devices.
So just before I
start that, I'd love
to get a show of hands, who
here has used Chrome OS before.
That's awesome.
Who here has a Chrome OS
device with them right now.
And if you do have it,
could you hold it up.
All right, great.
All right, thank you.
So the Chrome OS team are on a
live stream in the Googleplex,
and they're watching all this.
So we're always really excited
to see folk using Chrome OS,
so thank you for doing that.
So for those of you who have
been exposed to Chrome OS
before, have come
across it before,
and have spoken to us
before, you're probably
very familiar with
these three ideas.
We've been very consistent
about the ideas behind Chrome OS
since we started.
We want Chrome OS to be fast--
fast to start up, fast to use.
We want it to be easy.
We want it to be easy to use.
It's a tool.
The way that we
think about it is we
want Chrome OS to
get out of the way,
so you can get to
where you want to go.
We don't want to show pop ups
announcing a driver update,
selling you
productivity software.
You should just get to
where you want to go.
And security, that's been top
of mind for us since Chrome OS
began.
So that's led to some
big moments for us
over the last few years.
So at I/O last year we announced
that Chromebook shipments
overtook Macs in
the United States.
Now, that's in part due
to our strength in edu
where Chromebooks outsell
every other device combined.
But that's also been
the case in retail.
So we've seen nearly 20% growth
year on year and holiday weeks
up to 50% growth.
So Chrome OS is really
strong and continues to grow.
But as we talk today
about optimization,
it's not just helpful
for Chrome OS.
So phones like
the Samsung Galaxy
S8 with its desktop projection
mode use a windowing system,
and a lot of the
optimizations we
talk about today will
be helpful for that too.
There's also devices that
are in a laptop format that
run Android, like the Lenovo
Yoga Book and the A12.
They use keyboard.
They use touchpad input.
So thinking about how to
optimize for Chrome OS
will help for these
form factors too.
So let's talk a little
bit about desktop apps,
and how they're different
from the mobile form factor.
So mobile apps,
for myself I tend
to use them in short
bursts, maybe a few minutes,
maybe 20 minutes at a time.
And if I think about
buying a mobile app,
it's something that
could cost a few dollars.
Desktop apps, I and maybe many
of you use those for many hours
at a time during the day.
And buying one of those--
buying that for a few hundred
dollars is not unreasonable.
So these simple changes in the
form factor, a bigger screen,
faster input with
mouse and keyboard
drive a really
different kind of usage.
And the first thing that we
might think about as Android
developers is how do we
extend our current app
onto the desktop platform,
and then ongoing,
we may think about
other opportunities
to do something very different
on the desktop platform.
So that different
type of usage has been
reflected in our own analytics.
So we've seen that users
who are using immersive apps
like messaging,
gaming, productivity
spend more time on that
app in a Chromebook
than they do on mobile devices.
And so an example is AutoCAD.
So I met a couple
of the developers
back there who
are with us today.
Thanks for coming.
They've been working with
us to try and optimize,
and some of the usage that
we've seen on Chrome OS devices
has been much stronger.
So let's talk a little bit about
some of, though, the high level
specifics about what
you can do to optimize
for Chrome OS and also
these large screen
and other types of devices.
First, Chromebooks work like
any other Android device.
So if you have an app in
the Google Play Store,
it probably already
works on Chrome OS.
Many developers test
only for mobile, which
is completely understandable.
Just seeing the app for the
first time running on Chrome OS
will probably
illustrate the need
to do some optimization work.
Those optimizations
usually come down
to four differences
between mobile and desktop.
The first is wider screens.
That's probably the
most common issue.
So, of course,
your mobile device
has a screen that's this wide.
Your laptop device will have
a screen that's this wide.
And some apps don't use
screen real estate maybe
like they should.
And that's not just
third-party apps.
This is work that
we have to do too.
So this is an example of Maps
running in the "explore around
you" view on Chrome OS.
And you can see there's a narrow
strip of content in the middle,
and the content's not
reflowing properly
to take up gaps on the
side of the screen.
This is another example.
This is a conversation
from Google Hangouts.
And as you can see, each message
from each of the participants
is hard aligned to
the left and right.
So it's hard to read downwards.
The eye has to jump
from side to side
to get the gist of
the conversation.
The second item, phone's
a default portrait,
laptop's a default landscape.
So this is an example.
This is "Storm 4: Rise of
the Balur," an Android game.
Chrome OS respects that setting
that locks an app to portrait.
So on a landscape
screen, the screen is--
the view is still in portrait.
So that leaves a lot
of the screen blank,
and as you can see here,
those rich graphics
are locked in this strip in
the center of the screen.
The third item is windowing.
So many apps assume
that the display size
is equal to the window
size, and that's not always
the case, even on Android.
Part of the value
of desktop, though,
is multitasking, being able to
see lots of different windows
and apps running
at the same time.
So it's often not the
case that the window size
is equal to the display size.
Apps need to understand that.
So for example,
they can correctly
understand the
input of a stylus,
for example, and draw the
ink in the correct position,
and there's no offset errors.
And finally, keyboard,
pointer, and stylus input.
So there's lots of
common states here
that are uncommon on mobile.
So for example, hover
states that will show things
like tool tips.
So hover over an icon,
a tool tip appears.
It's just really unusual to
be able to do that on mobile.
And the reverse is also true.
So states and actions that
are really common on mobile
could be less common on desktop.
So an example, swipe to
dismiss, for example,
of an email or an item in a
list, that's super easy to do
and very intuitive
on mobile where you
have touch that's right there.
Whereas on desktop,
doing that with a mouse
is a little more unusual.
Those kinds of updates
that we're talking about
can be very simple.
So let me give you an example.
So we've been working closely
with the team at Slack,
and so this is an example of
Slack app running on Chrome OS.
So those of you who
use Slack are probably
familiar that in
the bottom right
here, there's a big box for
entering your next message
and sending it out to the team.
So if you type that
in and press Enter,
originally that just
sent a carriage return,
because the mobile device wasn't
used to seeing keyboard input.
So it wasn't tested,
very understandable.
But the Slack team helped
us to do a little work
optimizing this, and now hitting
Enter will send a message,
so it works like you'd expect.
So this is a quick
summary of the top level
items that will help
those apps work like you'd
expect on desktop and
get you happier users.
So with that I'd like
to introduce Stefan,
our tech lead for window
management on Chrome OS.
[APPLAUSE]
STEFAN: Hello, everyone.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm here to talk about how
to improve your application
for the use in the
desktop world, which
means with Chromebooks
or large screen devices.
The most important thing you
can do to your application
in order to get the best
out of desktop world
is go to at least API level 24.
Because with API level 24 we
can remove all the restrictions
of window sizes
and whatnot which
we have actually put in place
for [? older ?] applications.
The next big thing you should
really do is you should--
you should use
both orientations.
So as we have seen
earlier, so the thing is
most applications are coming
nowadays in phone size,
means like it's portrait.
And the thing is portrait alone
is, yeah, good for a phone,
but it's not good for a desktop.
So therefore by having also
landscape at the same time,
you are improving the
usage of your application
on a desktop device.
The next thing--
well, if you ever
have to only really rely on one
orientation, which is possible,
you can actually specify that.
And please specify
that in the manifest
so that we know that
this is the case.
The next thing you
should do is, well, there
are different sizes of screens.
You might actually have
something which is 10 inch,
but you might actually have
something which is 40 inch,
or maybe something like that.
I don't know who has
that in the living room,
but it would be nice, right?
So and with that
you definitely want
to show, of course,
more content.
And therefore, by using the
standard mechanisms which
are already in Android,
multiple layouts and whatnot,
you can do all these
kind of things.
Yeah, and then there
is mouse and keyboard.
While mouse and
keyboard is something
which is totally useful on
a notebook, but on a phone
you have probably never really
used it with a good reason.
So the next thing is
you should actually
add stuff for accessibility,
like for example,
adding content descriptions
so that the user can actually
hear what you are doing there.
So and then there
are, of course,
all the usual suspects
like, for example,
all these old APIs which are
there already since ever.
Like drag and drop support.
It's like the hover API
which we have heard earlier
and all these kinds of things.
By doing so, you are doing
a perfect job of getting
into a good desktop experience.
And most of these APIs
are already there.
There's nothing really new.
And by doing that, you are also
getting a much better citizen
on the phone world.
So with that, coming to the
window management on Chrome OS.
So we have learned some
lessons from our previous year.
So in our previous
year, we had, well,
our first incarnation,
which was built on M,
and, yeah, it has
a lot of problems.
We said it was beta,
and beta it was.
Well, there are millions
of applications.
There are many different APIs.
Well, back then it
was 24, now it's 26.
And if you're going
online, you are
trying to search, for
example, on how to figure out
what the size of the screen is.
Well, you will get 30
different versions of how
you can do that or even more.
And the thing is everything
will be uploaded.
Well, that tells you if
something will go wrong--
well, can go wrong, it
will definitely go wrong.
There's no question there.
So and then there were the
problems of orientations.
Like for example, you're
starting an application,
starts out landscape, then
it changes to portrait,
and it jumps around.
And this is of course totally
annoying for the user.
And we had some
good ideas in mind
of actually adding there
a special button which
allowed you to change
the orientation
at any point in time.
Which was-- which
was well thought,
but the problem is that
since an application could
at any point in time say, hey,
I really want to be portrait,
suddenly, the button was
disappearing and it was gone.
So which was, of course, also
very confusing to the user.
So then we had application
restarts, so unexpected ones.
So like, for example, the
window changes its size,
and it lost its state,
and the user then
had to actually restart the game
from the beginning, which was,
of course, totally annoying.
All these kind of
things were pretty bad.
So and at the end, we
had then, of course,
the problem that the
windows, they didn't really
expect to be in a windowed
world to begin with,
which was another problem.
Which brings me
to our next thing.
So this [? app ?] in
our new window manager
is a special window
modes we are supporting.
So essentially we have the
pre-density aware applications.
These are always being
shown full screen.
So I really hope
that you are not
programming any of these
kinds of applications
anymore unless you want
to have the biggest
button of the world.
Might be a good thing, but
you possibly don't want that.
So the next thing
is pre-N, pre-N.
That is something in
between that means--
it includes Marshmallow.
Well, we figured out that most
of the applications out there,
they are working fine.
So they are working
reasonably well.
But the thing is there are a
lot of applications which don't.
So with that we were getting a
lot of beta feedback and so on.
So and in order to
resolve this issue,
we have put them
all into windows.
So they are static now.
They have always the same size.
It's like it's coming
up in phone size.
So and it can then be either
landscape or portrait.
The user has an option where
he can actually then say, hey,
I want to have that thing as
big as possible, which makes it
then a portrait-sized window
on a landscape screen,
which is the biggest
thing that you can do.
And if it rotates, it's not
filling the screen entirely.
But that is pre-N.
If you are moving to N--
what I told you already,
it's a good idea to do--
you have then the full
freedom of getting resizable.
You can actually
be full screen, you
can be windowed,
and so on and so on.
And if you don't want
to be resizable in N,
you can say, I want
to be unresizable,
which essentially puts
you in the full desktop.
And then the last thing
is you can actually
have an application which
essentially dictates as, hey, I
want to be this size and at this
location, and we respect that.
So the big change
to previous versions
was that we have a
new rule, and that
is that the root activity
rules, which essentially means
that the root activity is--
well, you have
multiple activities
which are making up
the task [INAUDIBLE].
And the top activity is
the one which you see,
and the bottom most one,
that is the root activity.
So if the root activity is, for
example, let's say landscape,
and it's resizable, that means
that every activity which
goes on top is also
landscape and resizable.
That sounds a little
bit weird, right?
Because the thing
is, that would mean
that if you have an
application which
was meant to be portrait
and maybe unresizable,
it could suddenly become
resizable and landscape, which
is a contradiction
in itself, right?
Well, the thing is first,
if you're looking on a phone
and you have the
side by side mode,
the same thing is
being done there.
And the second
thing is that most
of the applications which are
really locked into one mode
are games.
So and the games they usually
don't use layouts and whatnot,
and therefore, they really
need this treatment.
But once you are using a layout
and the standard framework,
which gives you all
this kind of thing,
it can really hold
your form-- your stuff
so that it's still
usable that way.
And with this, you
have no window jumping,
everything looks much
cleaner to the user,
and it's really a
good experience.
So and then there is,
well, you have possibly
seen already Chromebooks.
Chromebooks look like this.
But if you have not seen
it, you can also convert it
into a tablet form factor.
So what happens when you're
going into the tablet form
factor?
In that case, we are
actually forcing the size
if it's an M application-- so
the size will actually then
be restricted to
whatever it was before.
But the orientation
can go exactly
as you are doing it on
a phone, which means,
the root activity doesn't have
any kind of impact on that
anymore.
So orientation, I mentioned
that earlier already we
have, well, two
orientations, which
is portrait and landscape.
While one is good for phones,
one is good for, well,
tablets and notebooks.
And then there's unspecified.
Unspecified means
you can do both.
We definitely encourage you to
do that, because that's best.
So, and if you really have
to use one of these things,
please specify that
in your manifest file.
Please put in that you
have to be landscape.
Don't make us guess what you
might actually want or want not
to, because we
cannot guess that.
So therefore, if
you want to avoid
jumping or any kind
of weird scenario,
please put that in there.
So and then-- oh, look at that.
So if you are specifying
your orientation,
you should definitely
specify also [? sensor. ?]
Because the problem is when I'm
playing a game or something,
or I'm using Android, and
I'm going from this mode
into this mode, which
is very natural,
right, it's upside down.
And the other thing
is the camera is here.
See?
It's here.
It's not there like on a phone.
So it doesn't even make much
sense to actually say, hey,
I need the camera on top,
because it's not really
on top of [INAUDIBLE] anyways.
And the worst thing
which can be done,
that is going into the
manifest file, specifying
your landscape, and
then call later on, set
requested orientation
with another orientation.
That is really throwing
off everything,
so please don't ever do that.
So launch sizes, you have
various possibilities
to actually get a certain
window in a certain size.
So there are first hints.
This is something
new which we have
done, especially for our form
factor, which means desktop.
You can especially
give us some hints.
What do you want to see
inside a desktop environment?
So do you want to have a
small window, a big window?
Should it be landscape?
Should it be portrait?
By specifying these
kind of things,
you should actually be
put into the right size
without varying of which
size exactly it is.
And the next thing
is you can actually
start your intent with a
special options command, which
is already there since N. And
by specifying the set launch
bounds, you can then
move your window
to a certain size and location.
And the last possibility you
have is for every intent,
you can also specify
a layout command,
which allows you to give you
a minimum size, a default
size, and where
it should actually
be laid out on the screen.
Should it be left,
right, top, and so on.
So what kind of window
modes do we know?
Well, we know, of
course, windowed as we
are running on a desktop.
And in this case, if you're
running in this mode,
you will actually
run in, I think,
it's 5x size screen on
that screen, so which is--
which is in portrait.
If you are maximized,
you will actually
see the caption or the
application control bar on top,
and the window will always
cover the entire screen.
So even if you
are only portrait,
the rest will be
blanked out with black.
And then if you
are in this mode,
your application can then
request to be full screen.
It can actually do
the standard stuff,
which is also always
common on Android
to simply say, I want to
take over the system UI,
I want to be full
screen, and then
we are going out of
your way and the caption
and as well as the
shelf will be hidden.
Yeah.
The most important thing to get
more space being used properly
is add more layouts
for bigger sizes.
So you can actually--
well, the thing is the more
sizes you have, the
better it is, especially
with bigger sizes.
Avoid restarting if, well,
there are some applications.
If you are not using
the layout system,
you should try to
avoid the resizing
and do the on layout
change commands yourself.
Because that way
you can actually
get a smooth experience.
We come to that one later.
However, you should always
use [? unsafe ?] instance
and unrestore instance,
because that is helping you
on Android world, as well
as on the Chromebook world.
As better the restore
function is as better
it is for the user.
The only thing on a
phone is you don't really
notice it that much,
but if you have a window
and suddenly the content is
gone and you see something else
from the beginning,
that is quite annoying.
So and-- oh, yeah.
If you are resizing the window,
you should definitely make sure
that if there are some elements
on the screen which you cannot
access and they are simply
gone, don't try to access them.
We have seen some applications
crashing because of that,
and that was, of course,
not fixable by us.
So here's a good example
for a large screen layout.
And you probably know it, and
you have seen it since years,
but it's always a good
thing to show again.
So there is a
portrait application.
Well, portrait shows
you only one line.
And you have then
the landscape version
where you get simply another
part of the screen like that.
So which is something which
you have seen with fragments
already sent a long time.
So next thing is Netflix
users, the whole screen
efficiently to display the
title's imagery, synopsis,
and episode list to give you the
user's contextual information
before hitting play.
So one thing, what I
was mentioning earlier
is there is, unfortunately,
a caption or a window control
bar.
This thing is,
unfortunately, at least
for now part of
the window, so it
is inside your view hierarchy.
If you are now putting something
into the root of the view
hierarchy, you might actually
mess up something there.
So for the time being,
we should really
encourage you to not do
these kind of things.
And according to
the framework team,
this is something that shouldn't
do it anyways, so therefore try
to avoid that if possible.
The next thing is you
should actually always
make sure to not assume that the
top left corner of your window
is at 0, 0.
It's most certainly not, because
there is first the caption,
and then comes your content.
So always try to
get your coordinates
relative to the content origin.
And if you have the window
size from your application,
you will actually get the window
size, including the captions.
So essentially that
means that your content
is a little bit smaller
than the real full window.
Window resizing has a lot
of hurdles, unfortunately.
So, as I mentioned earlier,
to make it seamless,
you should really have the
save and restore functionality.
And, again, this thing is
something which helps you also
in the Android world.
This is not really only
something for Chromebooks.
You should have that
anyways, either way.
So and if you are using
on configuration change
and you are doing
dynamic layouting, please
add that there as well.
If you don't want to be
resized, you can actually put
into your activity
resizable [? forms, ?]
which is for the most part true.
There are some [INAUDIBLE]
cases where you can get resized,
but usually this is true.
And your window size will not
be the display size for sure.
So therefore, always use
getActivity, getResources,
getConfiguration, screen
width, and height and [? dp ?]
in order to figure out what the
real size of your window is.
Oh, yeah.
So then the next thing is to
get the current configuration
of the screen and the
matrix and everything,
you should use getResources,
getConfiguration,
which was more or less in
the plan before already.
So the window balance can
change at any point in time.
So be aware of that this--
that you're not really
aesthetically caching the size
of the screen or the window
somewhere.
We have seen that also in some
applications which are simply
first time they run, they
simply get then the size
of the screen, they store it
somewhere in there own data,
and they never look at it again.
They scale everything,
and thereafter when
you resize the window,
everything is looking funny.
Really, try to
avoid that as well.
So and then, yeah, if you're
using the layout system,
everything will be
done automatically.
Otherwise, you have to
take care of it yourself.
You can do that
via OpenGL, which
has been resizing
pretty nicely, but yeah.
So if you have a
native application,
you should actually
get the start size.
Looking at the M last
content, XY [INAUDIBLE]
width and height.
You should actually-- you
could also use your content,
and you should definitely
then listen to all the changes
which are coming down the
pipe via the listeners.
So definitely look at
any kind of changes
which can happen to the layout
and/or your window size.
So with that, let me show you a
short demonstration by Margaret
Chang about resizing.
MARGARET CHANG: Great.
Thanks, everyone.
My name is Margaret,
and today, I'll
be showing you some
pretty cool things
that your Android apps
can do on Chrome OS.
Actually, I have here one of the
latest Chromebooks, the Samsung
Chromebook Pro, that
will be releasing soon
with the Nougat [? rebase ?]
of the Play Store on Chrome.
So let's get started.
You can see that it's pretty
small on the screen, right.
So from here it's
very hard to see.
I'm going to go ahead
and resize the app,
and again, I could
typically do that
by hitting this little Maximize
button or the Full Screen key.
But I actually have a
developer option enabled
that lets me perform
freeform resizing by dragging
the borders of the window.
So see that?
The content scales really
well and very beautifully.
And the content also
updates dynamically.
So if you're able to
do something like this
into your app, you'll be giving
your users much more control
over their desktop real estate.
And with that, I'm going
to send you back over
to Stefan to talk about just how
you can enable these developer
options so that you can also
try these on your apps, too.
STEFAN: Sweet.
Thank you, Margaret.
So to get to the developer
options, all you have to do
is you have to go first
into the Chrome window,
you go into the Settings,
and you type in Android.
And then you will see the
highlighted Android section
and you click on
Android Settings.
A side tip, you should actually
now go into your shelf,
right click on it, and
pin it to the shelf,
so that you can access it later
on quicker when you need to.
And with that, so there are
currently two developer options
of interest for you.
The first one is the
dynamic resizing option.
So you should definitely
turn that on and try
to test your application.
See that it's actually
first dynamically
fluidly resizing everything.
So if it's not resizing
fluidly, what you should do
is you should actually
look into your activate.
So if it is not
dynamically doing that,
and you're using
the layout system,
and you are getting
restarted, you
should actually make sure
that all the resources which
you are using, they are cached.
That you're not trying
to reallocate them again,
because that takes time and
that makes the whole process
much leggier and it
doesn't look that good.
So and as you have seen
just in our demonstration,
it can be really, really smooth.
So therefore the
smoother and nicer it is.
And then the next
thing is, well,
as I said earlier, we have
this kind of root [? rule. ?]
And you don't really know
exactly what your window is
doing.
And if you ever
come to the point
where you are not really
sure what you see,
you can always turn on the
second option with this
to show the content-- well,
the state of the Window
Manager, which is then presented
in the window title bar.
As you can here
see, for example,
there's N resizable, LU.
Which means that it's the state.
U means it can do both.
It's currently a
landscape, and it's
an N resizable
application, which is
the best thing what can happen.
So and the second option--
no.
Actually I was joking.
There's a third option.
So there is another one if
you want to also test already
maximize, you can actually
turn on an option which
is named something like default
size and orientation, yada,
yada, yada.
And you put that
thing into use phone
sized window and default
to portrait orientation
and allow portrait-only
application to maximize.
So if you select that thing, you
can also maximize your portrait
applications.
Which gives you then the control
bar, everything as I said.
So we have not turned
that on yet by default,
but it'll come sooner or later.
So therefore you can already
go ahead and try that, as well.
So then if you're
using a camera,
you have most certainly
already seen something
in our previous
experiments with M.
That was you were
starting an application,
and suddenly
everything was somehow
rotated, which was
not really that great.
So and the question is how can
you fix these kind of things.
Well, the first thing
that we want to tell you
is, if you are
moving to at least N
and you make your window
resizable, we take care of you.
So with that, we should be
able to make everything work
for you.
But without that,
unfortunately, you
might actually hit some
edge cases which don't work.
So, therefore, simply doing
that will fix everything.
So from Window Manager
to input-related topics.
Well, the thing is,
as I said earlier,
phones are a little
bit different.
And I guess you have
possibly never used
the keyboard or the mouse
with your phone, right?
Yeah, me neither.
So the first thing
which you should do
is there are input focus
elements on your screen.
So the thing is at
the moment Android
is trying to guess
what you might actually
want to have there,
how you are actually
navigating through that.
On a desktop, you expect a
little bit more than that.
So by using, for
example, tap key,
you want to actually
tap through them,
you have-- want to
use directional keys.
And this is something which
is an Android since ever.
However, the thing
is like it was not
really used that much, because
the keyboard was not used.
So if you want to use that,
you can simply add that
to your manifest file as pointed
out here, as pointed out,
I think, API level,
I don't know, 12.
Something really pretty old.
So, therefore, simply go
online and check it out.
It's totally easy to do, and
it helps a lot of people--
especially for
accessibility and so on.
So the next thing is if you
want to handle keyboard actions,
you can use key event
and call back handler.
So this thing will allow you to
actually get all the keyboard
events directly and to do
something with it, like,
for example, in a game.
You can also use
then the modifiers
to check out if, for example,
the Shift key was pressed
or something, and you can do
then special actions on that.
You don't have to
really re-implement,
of course, the text edit field.
That is already there.
But if you ever
want to edit text,
you should actually
use [? onkeydown, ?]
[? onkeylongpress, ?] and
[? onkeyapp ?] to do your text
detection.
Please don't use [? onkey ?]
[? preIME ?] unless you really
want to implement
the full IME stuff.
You don't want to do that.
Please leave this to us and
use only the key for [? not ?]
[? handling. ?] And off to
Margaret for our text input
demo.
MARGARET CHANG: Thanks, Stefan.
OK, Adobe is a developer
that is taking the next step
into implementing their keyboard
shortcuts into their Android
app which typically
breaks the barrier
between your traditional
mobile and desktop users.
All right, here I'm going
to go ahead and show
you some shortcuts that
Adobe has implemented
into their Lightroom app.
Here's a collection
of some photos
that I already
have in my library.
And the first thing
I'm going to do
is try to go through each photo
and rate them from 0 to 5 stars
by pressing on the corresponding
numbers on the keypad.
So let's get started.
I remember this was
an amazing meal, so 3.
Beautiful place,
beautiful picture, so 5.
Delicious meal, but homemade
so 4, and so on and so forth.
You can see here that I
was also able to traverse
through the photos using
the navigational arrow keys.
All right, so now let's
say I want to make
a collection of food photos.
I can easily do that by
pressing X to reject, P to pick,
and if I want to reverse this
at any time, I can click U.
You can see how easy I was
able to go through and organize
my photos.
If you were able
to also implement
some of these keyboard
shortcuts into your apps,
you'll also be able to increase
user productivity workflow,
as well.
So with that, I'll
hand it back to Stefan
to talk more about how to
utilize some other hardware
features like mouse and stylus.
STEFAN: Thank you, Margaret.
So with every
Chromeware supports now
a stylus, as you have
probably seen already
with all our latest editions.
Well, there that--
I can't find it.
Oh, it's not there.
Great.
OK, so if you don't
care about any kind
of input-related things, like
what kind of device it is,
well, you're done.
You don't have to do anything.
Because if you're using
already the motion event,
that is all fine.
If you are, on the other hand,
interested in, for example,
pen input, well, then you should
actually call the motion event
[? get ?] [? two ?] type, which
gives you exactly the kind
of device you are using.
You can get then the
pressure and the tilt.
So however, the thing
is, of course, you
are getting one of
these events only
per frame, which
means, like, you're
missing out on all the
precision what we can give you.
So in order to get
everything, you
want to have the
precision movements.
And for that, you
should actually
have an additional look
into getHistorical,
XY, and pressure
and axis value which
gives you then the full pass.
So the other thing that we have
is a very sophisticated palm
rejection, which means
like even though when
you are using your
palm on the screen,
it will actually not register
as some kind of drawing.
But the problem is
first you are already
getting some kind of event.
So in order to make
everything work,
you're getting first the
[INAUDIBLE], pen goes down
or finger goes down.
And then you are moving
maybe a little bit
and then you get a cancel
call, which is essentially
canceling the entire pass, which
is a signal for you to remove
the entire thing.
Margaret will show us
now a nice demo for the--
MARGARET CHANG: Thank you.
OK, let's go over an
app that has really
utilized stylus input
well and also implemented
some specific stylus features.
So first I'm going to go
ahead and put my Chromebook
into tablet mode, because
it's much easier to write on.
All right.
Then I'm going to go ahead
and take out my trusty stylus
device, and let's get started.
OK, Squid is an app that
easily lets me draw and sketch.
And you can see here that as I
put my palm across the screen,
there are no marks from it.
At the same time, I can write
with my palm on the screen,
and there are no marks
from that-- from my palm.
This is because the system
is detecting the palm
and aborting the event path.
And then the app picks
that up and undoes
the line that has been
drawn so far from my palm.
So one thing Squid
has also done is
they've implemented a pressure
sensitivity feature, which
you can see here.
So what that does
is it allows me
to make lighter or darker lines
based off of how hard I press
on the screen.
This means that lighter lines
are from lighter pressure
and darker lines are
from heavier pressure.
So with that I'm going
to send you back over
to Stefan to wrap up inputs.
STEFAN: Thank you, Margaret.
Next thing is input
compatibility mode.
So the thing with
the compatibility
is, well, very simple.
No one was actually
using a mouse yet, right?
So therefore, the scroll
wheel has a special input.
It is defined by Android since
ever, but no one is using it.
On a Chromebook, this is,
of course, pretty bad.
Because if you're using then,
for example, your mouse,
nothing will move when
you're trying to scroll.
In order to solve this, we
have a compatibility mode.
So and what we do is we look at
that thing, we have the event,
and we are converting
it automatically
in a touch scroll event.
And that is usually done
under the hood for you.
If you don't care about
these kind of things,
everything will simply work.
However, if you do care
about these kind of things
and other special
input [? quilts, ?]
you can actually specify in the
user section of your manifest
file, Android hardware type PC.
If you do that--
and please use as false,
because otherwise you
run only on
Chromebooks-- then you
will get the full breadth
of all the different input
events possible.
And yes, since we are
running a bit short,
I'll try to speed
this up a little bit.
So that means, you're
actually getting then
the proper scroll events,
and you can also then
check out the--
you can distinguish the
two finger touch touchpad
scrolling from the
touch screen scrolling
by looking at getSource.
And you can distinguish
also the drag operation,
the drag and drop operation
from the touchpads collection.
So this brings me now
to the last paragraph,
how to test the application
to ensure a positive user
experience.
So first off, you
should definitely
make sure that all your
manifest files are in order.
So which means check out
that you are specifying
the orientation you want to
use, the size you want to use,
[INAUDIBLE] if you want
to use them, and check out
that the min width, max width,
and all these kind of things,
they are actually
specified properly.
If you're interested
in the special events,
use Android hardware type
PC, which will definitely
give you all the events.
Then you should definitely test
the resizing of your window.
So make it really long.
Try to resize your window
as crazy as possible.
Use our developer
option and make sure
that everything is smooth
and it's not crashing.
And then also change the device
from tablet into notebook form
factor to see that
everything is working fine.
And also make sure that caption,
so the window control bar,
is not offsetting your input
events by some kind of fraction
of the screen.
So and make sure that the
safe and restore is working
properly, that you are
restoring that properly,
and that everything
works there as well.
Yeah.
Very soon we will have
an emulator for you.
You should actually
take out your phone.
You should actually make a
screenshot of this thing,
because nobody can remember
the very exciting shortcut,
goo.gl/Q8ptkZ.
If you want to sign up
for our virtual machine,
you can actually do it there.
And we will actually
send you, then,
a preview as soon as it's ready,
which should be fairly soon.
So with that, you
should actually
be able to develop
everything locally
without the need of
using a Chromebook.
If you have any more
specific questions,
then please go to
our developer site
on
developer.android.com/topic/arc,
and we will update this page.
It should be updated by now,
but we will add more stuff to it
over time.
So with that, let's summarize
and wrap up the session.
I'm doing that now very fast.
So the takeaway is your
application is already working.
Everything is fine.
You shouldn't really worry.
Well, maybe you should worry.
You should definitely
try it out.
move to API
level 24 unless you want to
be stuck into a small window.
Plan for huge screens,
very, very important.
Allow your application
to be resizable.
Make sure to specify vendor
requirements in your manifest
file, as mentioned earlier.
Be consistent with
the window orientation
and add all the nice
desktop features which
are making a desktop a desktop.
[MUSIC PLAYING]